bon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir les enfants mais qu'est ce que
tu as dont a sauté comme ça nounours pas
plat j'ai envie de danser et de chanter
patron je me sens en pleine forme ce
soir mon échelle
[Musique]
voilà pour les chats
l'eau
je vais descendre roi nicolas pas
preneur
je vais leur dire bonsoir
j'ouvre la fenêtre centre cendres hui je
crois qu'ils ont d'être tout surpris si
je vois ils sont sales
[Musique]
sont trop de tapage
dauchot boussouar les enfants dans un
immense on est sage
alors on danse en avant moi je vais
danger aujourd'hui avec les petits je
vais vous montrer
regardez on ne peut pas se tromper trois
noms nous lama mais surtout tenons nous
bien d'abord on va tourner et par là de
ce côté mais gentiment sans bouskila 2
puis on va s'arrêter à tire de l'autre
côté hommes ont fait une promenade
que ces chats main et j'ai dit à mes
amis aussi
si ça vous plaît tant mes enfants venez
pas ici un petit tour par six veuves ou
prix et c'est réussi et maintenant
chantant en choeur en avant les bons
danseurs
bravo les enfants ce que vous pensez
bien
milka et on est fatigué moi c'est la fin
de la journée c'est le moment de se
coucher
nous faisons comme nos amis ils sont
tous au
lee nous y allons aussi c'est un sans
nuage j'en suis certaine le marchand de
sable vienne il nous dira fermez vos
yeux et dormait tous les deux nous
sommes bien dans notre lit non non vous
souhaite bonne nuit
sa grosse voix me fait plaisir quand je
vais m'endormir je vais m'endormir sa
foi nous fait plaisir
paul ii du laizon au gîte à être bon
tél
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir les enfants embrasse bien fort
votre papa et votre maman est allée
sagement vous coucher comme pimprenelle
et nicolas opposeront ce qu'ils sont
mignons
dobs allons en route fidèle compagnon
aux nuits des enfants à demain oddo beau
bonhomme